a federal judge who you appointed has
just ruled that you must give CNN
reporter Jim Acosta his press pass back
your reaction to the ruling fine I mean
it's not a big deal what they said
though is that we have to create rules
and regulations for conduct et cetera et
cetera we're doing that we're going to
write them up right now it's not a big
deal and if he misbehaves we'll throw
them out
or we'll stop the news conference nobody
believes in the First Amendment more
than I do and if I think somebody's
acting out of sorts
I will leave I'll say thank you very
much everybody I appreciate you coming
and I'll leave and those reporters will
not be too friendly to whoever it is
that's acting up well that was President
Trump during an interview that will air
in full on Fox News Sunday with Chris
Wallace CNN reporter Jim Acosta has
regained access to the White House but
the administration is expected to
address reporter conduct with new
regulations joining us now is White
House press secretary
Sarah Sanders who I used all of my
powers of persuasion to get her into the
studio tonight so one of the statements
that came out of the White House today
was a statement from you that indicated
that there were rules being developed
and a protocol being developed when will
we expect to see what that looks like I
think the biggest thing to take away is
and the place that we focused on is
exactly what the president said we
support a free press but freedom of the
press doesn't mean freedom to be
disruptive freedom to be rude freedom to
interrupt and impede the ability of your
of the colleagues of the disruptive
reporter from actually being able to do
their jobs as well as White House staff
from being able to do theirs we've laid
out in a letter to CNN and their team
what we think were some of the missteps
that their reporter made at the press
conference on November 7th in a letter
that we sent them tonight and we expect
to see a response from that look that
the judge I think was actually very
clear that the White House has the
ability to say you can't come in you
don't have freedom of the press doesn't
mean free
to the White House and he said there has
to be due process and so that's what
we're doing and we'll see what happens
from there I mean the judge's ruling was
not a First Amendment ruling it was a
Fifth Amendment rule exactly he never
said that
CNN had been denied their First
Amendment rights because obviously they
can say whatever they want the
government including the White House has
never said here's what you can't say
they also have 50 plus additional people
that have that are hard pass holders at
CNN they actually are one of the
individual outlets that has the most
hard passes of any news outlet in the
country is CNN they're one of the top
three and so the idea that they aren't
able to get information that they need
from the White House is frankly
laughable well let me ask you some
processed question how many seats are in
that press room
I believe there's 49 seats so 49 total
seats there are thousands of journalists
across America who gets to decide whose
rear ends occupy 49 seats and how come
they get them and thousands of others
never ever get to darken the door that
place so if we work with a White House
Correspondents Association but they are
the primary people that help determine
who those seats belong to do they
actually get to pick them art can you
say okay on this next Thursday we're
going to have journalists from anywhere
in the country except Washington well
tradition has been in the past of the
White House Correspondents Association
determines who sits in that room and who
sits in those into that strid ition it's
not law true and so if there if there
was a desire to give other journalists
an opportunity to do it because I mean I
think some people see these same folks
in there every day and they say how come
they get to do it and I'm sure there are
broadcasters and print reporters all
over America who would love to be able
to come and ask the president questions
and probably wouldn't keep talking if he
asked them to stop I think that's
certainly an option to explore and maybe
we will in this White House I know the
president is one of the most accessible
presidents probably ever but certainly
in modern history he's taken in the last
six weeks leading up to the midterms he
took 300 times the number of questions
from reporters than either of his
predecessors that's out ray
ages to pretend that this is a president
who doesn't support the press doesn't
support freedom of the press and hasn't
given unprecedented access to those
reporters he's somebody who loves to
engage with the press but we've noticed
that we have and and that's because he
loves to be able to say directly to the
American people we never want to
prohibit that from taking place but at
the same time those individuals can't be
disruptive they can't impede the ability
of any individual to do their jobs so
when might we see the rules are the
requirements the protocol you've said
you sent the letter there CNN tonight is
that going to be in a few days a few
weeks you know we'll work with our team
on that and certainly moving into
Thanksgiving holiday we'll see how long
that process takes but I think there are
some just standard practices look I
think the the very basic minimum is that
if certain reporters like Jim Acosta
can't be adults than CNN needs to send
somebody in there who can be so if he
asked three questions when he was only
supposed to give one does that not make
those other reporters a little ticked
off that he he got more of the candy out
of the bold and they're gonna get I'm
not gonna speak for any of the other
reporters I'll leave that to them but
certainly privately a number of them
have expressed their displeasure with
the fact of his grandstanding and the
position that he often puts a lot of
them in and it's certainly not something
that they want to celebrate nor defend I
don't want to belabor it let's move to
tomorrow you're going to California with
the president you'll be looking at some
horrific scenes worst fires in the
history of the country
63 known dead 600 unaccounted for
what will the president hope to say to
the people of California in that visit
tomorrow I think the simplest message is
that we're here we're there for you we
will do any and everything we can to
provide federal assistance and federal
resources he conveyed that I know in a
call to Governor Brown earlier this week
he'll be joining us when we get to
California tomorrow I think this will
actually probably be one of the harder
days that we've had in the two years of
this administration not only visiting
with the horrific and
and seeing the scenes of the horrific
wildfires that have ravaged California
but also talking with some of the people
and the families that were impacted by
the shooting there not too long ago it's
gonna be I think a very difficult day a
very emotional day and I think the
biggest message is the biggest takeaway
will be the president saying we're here
and thankfully the presidents got big
shoulders and I think he's gonna go
there to offer them up to people that
need somebody to lean on president had a
big moment this week on prison
sentencing reform and we've only got
about a minute and a half left so but I
want to cover this because I didn't see
a lot in the mainstream media they were
so busy because it was a good story so
usually it's a great story and this was
bipartisan you had people that really
range the full spectrum from the far
left to the far right and everyone in
between on a personal level I was
involved in this one of the committee's
that helped draft some of the policy
based on my own experiences this was
huge
this was major give me a synopsis of
what this legislation does that the
president pushed this week well I think
one of the biggest things is it brings
the country together it's something that
like you said it's a bipartisan it's
some an area where Republicans Democrats
everyone can come together and agree
that this is a good thing to show a
little grace and a little mercy in our
justice system something that hasn't
been done in a long time
we've had decades worth of bad decisions
that have been improperly placed people
and really I think longer sentences than
they deserved not allowed people to have
a life after prison and this is
something that is very important to the
president very important to Jared
Kushner who's done a tremendous job in
helping develop and really work this
this isn't something that happened
overnight it's been a year and a half
long process and I think you saw a
little bit of a culmination of that we
really appreciate the credit for that
and I hope he will 30 seconds and that's
all we've got but look earlier Tammy
Bruce on this show said well Sarah
Sanders is going to be leaving the White
House is there something you need to
tell your dad
I hope not not that I'm aware okay
because I was thinking I'm and I told
her I said well gee maybe you know
something I don't know I'm just the dad
I how would I know these things I think
it is one of the the greatest privileges
and certainly one of the greatest
opportunities of my life to serve in
this administration to work with
President Trump and the successes that
he's had in the first two years I think
he's going to have a lot more over the
next say there's the other people though
that will transition out I mean is there
going to be a huge amount of people
that'll probably every administration
has turnover particularly after the
midterms most people don't have the
stamina the president does I often say I
don't know how he's not tired because
the rest of us certainly are and that's
not new for any administration that
you'll have some people that will change
over but at the same time the
president's got an incredibly dedicated
team that wants to continue to see the
country move forward and we want to see
it one under President Trump if you are
going to do it would you let me know and
don't let me read it in the paper sure
as I might think it's fake news Sarah
thank you for coming in you bet not that
you had a choice but thank you for being
here